nein nein luca konnten die linke linke
darf nicht andere kiste kommt ich bin
teamspieler aber der schutz unseres nein
unser bett ist kaputt
hallo ich meine lieben freunde herzlich
willkommen zu einer runde etwas zusammen
mit max wir haben gedacht wir nehmen
einfach mal was auch für max kanal doch
noch was für meinen kanal das heißt wenn
ihr die andere hunde sehen weil könnte
auf max kanal gehen wo du dir erstmal
die sache da ja ich habe wieder nach
städten wird es schlechter geht im erst
gestern sehe ich dass luca so und erhält
falls ja ist ja eigentlich auch logisch
also theoretisch
wir stellen immer noch mal hin stelle
ich mir noch mal hin ja man ist mit dem
marsch auf jeden fall näher dran
das sind eigentlich eigentlich muss es
so sein arsch hinhalten
er ist ohne spaß macht's immer mit
zusammenspielen können wir diese map
nach sehen wir immer so ja oder die man
sonst weil wir halt immer in zweierteams
gefühlswelt zweier team aber immer wenn
ihr aufnehmen wir haben drei mal
irgendwie glaube ich dass zusammen
aufgenommen immer mit diesem app
gespielt da wahrscheinlich weil das
unsere stärke ist diesen papieren
brauchst du dich schon mal vor
ja irgendwie ein bisschen bisschen was
ums bett herum nur dass sie nicht direkt
durch werden können mit der faust ab
willst du das mal machen und durch
rennen direkt beiden anderen mit der
faust erstmal das kannst du besser ab
wann es schwer sich schon das gold hier
in der mitte gerettet das bisschen was
schon getrennt wurde übrigens mit da
machen uns mögen dann gehen wir direkt
in andere da machen wir mal ganz ganz
schnell hier
okay okay ich schaffe es wenn wir ganz
schnell sind so ganz ganz schnell wie du
es gerne sein möchtest ich habe mir
vielleicht sogar noch eine andere mann
zu spielen aber das ist natürlich nicht
gesagt dass wir das schaffen
wir probieren es einfach in dieser runde
jetzt gleich schon lange dauert ich muss
erst mal so ich hab schon leistung hast
du schon sich zum lieber gewinne mache
ich jetzt machen was hab ich gedacht
okay ich mache aus zwei bögen in baulich
zum silber und jetzt selber nämlich
selber ja keine ahnung ist einfach
reisen elemente sind mal silber nein
neben das mag immerhin und dann hast du
in deinem inventar hast ehrlich nexteer
am drücker ich bin gleich da beim eisen
silber ist es auch krank dass da unten
wiesen eigentlich an ender drache ein
komischer drängen
nach emsdetten echt ja den bogen grabner
ja und einem fall habe ich auch gedrückt
wow wow ich werde verfolgt denn liegt
hier auf dem weg wie ich verfolgt
ja der baut unseren weg ab der wahlrat
es ist schlimm ist halb so wild nimmt
oder einfach den fall ganz okay ich war
jetzt den weg wieder warum einfach etwas
zu fressen kurz so dürfen uns nicht aus
der mitte vertreiben lassen
ja das hat eine aufgabe was in der
mittel bisschen verteidigen damit läuft
durchs turnier gleich warum unser bett
noch ein bisschen besser an
ich muss auch besser aufpassen damit war
ich habe natürlich kein schwert wenn nun
mal mit einem kommen würdest dann werde
es wahrscheinlich ganz hilfreich
beschwert in dem mit hering in mainz mit
ich habe gold dass ich mir nichts kaufen
kann kommt nach 18 uhr
ich habe es nicht gemacht hatte hier
legal als martens müssen erst eine kiste
oder das übrig da hab ich nicht ich mal
ganz kurz das geld ja alles klar macht
dass wir haben aber echt wie sind wir
gehen immer eigentlich ganz gut ab wenn
wir so als team spielen wenn wir nicht
gerade mal gegen todes kemper team
spielen oder so dann habe ich dann auch
noch kein paar nennen ihre weise lustig
so zusammengespielt
dann werden wir also voll von denen
beleidigt weil die uns in unserer base
also wenn soweit wie irgendwie ein
schritt in richtung mitte gesetzt haben
sind direkt auf uns gerannt und haben
auf uns geschossen haben zeit gequält
und dann noch diese fragen konnten quasi
nun unser base bleiben was anderes blieb
uns nicht übrig oder dieser andere fügt
sich irgendwo verschanzt hat honda nicht
aushändigen abgeschossen von männlichen
abgeschossen werden können
ich wurde auch geschossen hier hast du
drei gold blogger ich habe ich schon 51
dann gehen wir zurück und wo ich hoffe
mal dass ich jetzt endlich unter
geschossen werde oder hat überhaupt
schon in einem bogen ja doch was hätten
wäre ja nicht abgeschossen worden
robin drüben ich hoffe dass man
schwertner ich mach das ja so was was
machen wir als nächstes
ich mache mir erstmal eine gute rüstung
die kiste aber ich bring mir ein
bisschen es heißt echt eisen scheiße ich
bin ein bisschen eisen mit und
aufstellungsbeschluss meine kiste oder
verändert packen
die brauchen wir nicht dass da das lohnt
sich nur wenn wir zwei stück am abend
das quatsch also nehmen einfach ein dann
richtig mich jetzt auch mal schön aus
hier
du hast ja auch ein fahrzeug kaufen
natürlich gerade muss die davon wollen
wir dann direkt schon mal auf dem team
draufgehen hast du gute rüstung und so
ja ich bin eigentlich relativ gute club
passt auch ein energydrink stimmen
energy drink den nutzer nachholen recht
vergessene kurze erklärung wird
verständlich energy drinks in bei luca
schnelligkeit schnelligkeits denke oh
gott als ein damit ich habe angst dass
er mich darunter she's too much
everything was schießt der haft ich viel
oder wie schiesse mal ein bisschen auf
mich wird geschossen auf denen auf ihn
schießt du überhaupt gerade erst gar
kein ich mache nein war das knapp alter
direkt
ich dachte längst ein bisschen ab
irgendwie ja ich bin immer besser ich
hatte alles dabei alte 13 silbereisen
aus scheiße das als echt kacke team
gameplays junges jetzt war man ja ich
habe auch nur also ich werde werde hier
auch die ganze zeit abgeschossen [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
ich da nicht denn gott schickt man kommt
jetzt zu uns und wir am arsch wenn
jedoch kommt ja das ist ein bisschen
kacke du hast du hast gute sache
naja ich hab einen bogen sonst hab ich
aber auch nicht außergewöhnlich
und doch ich habe gute sachen die kommt
zu uns die kommt zu uns kommt sonst
müssen wir runter zu wachsen
hast du etwas wertvolles nee ich zeit
mal eben ganz kurz nochmal alles ich
schieß gerade mit dem bogen die ganze
zeit offen
ich habe auch schon ein paar mal
getroffen also viel leben hat er nicht
mehr
jetzt drücken wir vorher sollten wir vor
ein kaputter tot
der grüne dahinten riecht ein bisschen
auf blanke hass blöcke bauen wir hier
welche hin wo ich stehe die grünes
runter gefallen er wurde untergeschoss
von dem game daran hat den bogen
so haben wir den alle mögen die gelten
wenn er in der mitte ist es halt machen
schätzing ja sehr sehr gut ich hab mir
ist gold geholt
gute sache team blau ist schon komplett
raus die ich gerade okay hinten von
welche von team grün hast du blöcke und
ja ich hab mir kriegst du sie ja ehrlich
ja auch bei dem nach hinten bei dem geld
geschah nachdem sich die mal dass das
restliche gold geben was ich habe das
irgendwie zu unserer band brings oder so
ich hoffe dass ich es hinkriegen
ich bin hinter die hinter ihr okay da
ist auch noch ein bisschen geld hier
kommt wieder einer von grün
okay ich gehe auf die ich gehe auf den
gehweg mit dem wald erstmals der holz
ist es silber da vorne spannende runde
auf jeden fall schon wieder ist noch mal
gold respawn wollen wir uns einfach eine
bombe ist eine ender perle kaufen und
warten lieber ab dass ich hier
überlaufen kann
die haben ja bürgen dahin müssen wir uns
ich kann ich drüber ich kann nicht über
die herbergen scheiße alter oder willst
du mir deine wertvollen oder ich geb dir
das gold die leute zurück ich gebe zu
team gelb weil die sind ja ich kann ja
nicht ich kann nicht weg aus der mitte
wald im grünen steht dahin und kämpft
mit einem bogen
ach so ja warten müssen wir sicheren weg
bauen wir dürfen nicht das ganze dorf
verlieren alter
er hat einfach alle selbst spitzer
beschwert hatte ich keinen bogen hat wie
viel gold hast luca 13-mal soll ich mal
laufen einfach warte ich könnte würde
warst du es jetzt ich bin in der
sicheren base schon mal in der mitte da
jetzt schießt auch niemand auf dich doch
der einen bogen der bogen gespannt
werden team gelb oder grün team grün
habe ich eigentlich oder beschluss
gerade da dürfte nichts passieren kann
wie einen seite kennt ihr geld aber
keine blöcke wie soll ich denn da rüber
kommen worüber bei uns dass stahl hat
irgend eine riesige mauer gebaut
ich hab gar keine blöcke [ __ ] magst du
musst kommen ja ich kann mich hinter mir
ist eine combo kam luca kam luca ja der
schießt auf dich die kommen jetzt ich
habe ein halbes herz ich habe ein halbes
jahr
ok ich hab' das gold 22 gold alter wo
ich nein nein luca kommt einer klinik in
gap andere kiste kommt ich bin ich hab
ihn vor junge hartmann
dafür steht jetzt erst mal das team will
ich sagen oder
ich muss erstmal jahre junge gegen aids
sterben alter was hält den einmal
verschwindet erstmal rüstung holen junge
und dann erstmal energy drink oder das
richtig action wir brauchen auf jeden
energy drink ich hab ich noch ein halbes
herz hat habe ich schnell alles in die
kiste gelegt und will dass ich zeit
nicht verliere wenn ich jetzt sterben
und dann hab ich nicht auf den typen mit
der hand gehabt dann auch schnell das
schwert rausgehen und hat man
angegriffen hätte das auf dem bogen
ich habe eigentlich ab 1 wie viel gold
hast du übrig 9
ok dann müssen wir die mitte darum wie
ein bisschen gold füreinander perle und
dann warte ich immer noch immer zuerst
noch ein paar blöcke alter team gelb die
hohe ziele
das panel alter immer team gelb nicht
das letzte mal was drauf team gelb ist
halt wirklich so diese diesem verdammten
wechsel mit dem geld wird nur blödmänner
immer lass mal dass gold in der kiste
wollen wir team gelb jetzt endgültig
zerstören
da kann man machen ich hab mir noch
immer rüstung gekauft hatte solche
solches nebeneinander perle zu team
gehen meinst du schaffst das ja sonst
auch machen da müssen wir ein bisschen
sparen dass du dir auch natürlich hoffen
kann
also es kann halt nur eine machen wenn
du es die zutraut kannst du es auch
weiter 13 gold kostet eine nanny macht
man dann gehe ich in die mitte
da ist ihm grünen gilt lassen auf dem
grün gehen der bots tage zu unserem
eisen eine sekunde
wenn ich jetzt halt runterfällt als ist
alles gold weg alter das ist immer die
sache wenn man so ein entfernt sich
herumträgt
alles klar also ich bin jetzt bereit ich
hab eigentlich die bestmögliche
ausrüstung hat den bogen
ich glaube nicht ich hoff mal rüber also
sollte ich mich allein im team wir
kümmern oder fragt man nicht aber keine
spitzhacke alters tod eine spitzhacke
hab ich wieder vergessen
in der kiste bei uns bei uns liegt eine
uralte hätte ich mal direkt safe weg
gebaut
da wollen sie gold holen
okay er geht zum team gelb dann lasse
ich ihnen die anderen ablenken und
einfach abgeschossen stücken wie es denn
geschafft was auf alter bewahrt sich um
etwa immer noch nie eine spitzhacke
lieber wieder zurück ich habe echt
keinen bock die ender feld zu verlieren
ja klar verstehe ich solche hier noch
eine spitzhacke ok und team gelb ist
hier schon wieder okay beide fun team
gelb sind weg beide todt nein sie sind
beide weg von ihrer base und ich werfe
die rennpferde zu ihrer base man nicht
von ball abgeschossen halter die sie ich
hab gleich verfehlt fast wieder alte
pass auf
schippmann road team games jetzt so dran
alter erstmal auf direktem weg so
beschissen scrubs gerade alter jojo barg
man aber gute also die beste bestes
neues das sind wir auf jeden fall
ziemlich sicher ich habe auch ein
bisschen gold wieder zurückgebracht
jetzt richtig gehabt ganz kurz alter ich
hab die sind einfach die ganze zeit in
der mitte bis zu schon rüber gelaufen
ich lag heute aber bessere sachen als
wir können sie ja quasi gar nicht
mitkommen ich bat ihn gäbe schon wieder
hinter mir sind jedem ihr alter markt
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] geht zurück geht zurück
lukrativ ich kann ich nicht ich bin tot
ich dachte du lebst seiner mitte du
läufst auf einmal zurück ja wahrlich
gold geholt haben und dann wäre ich
gestorben
oh man scheiße alter ist das defilee
grunde schon wieder ist richtig krass
gerade mega spannend und sicherheit
nicht schon wieder es vor allem auch
echt wieder langen geworden wären sogar
gleich noch einfach ein gespräch bieten
das ist so scheiße wenn ihr einfach in
der mitte kämen nein nein weil ich gut
runter geboxt ich war grad bei team gelb
an der diemel in der mitte ist hat
niemand kontrolliert gold-lena also es
ist kein jemanden der mit
ich bin hinter dir dann ich habe ihr
nichts ich gehe einfach zu irgendein
team durch holen wir das ganze gold
waziristan behalten lenkt die bis hinab
hier sind auch wieder zwei alter hier
liegen einfach vier gold holten punkt
okay dann hau ab mit dem gold gibt es
aber fast auf teamgeist unseres neuen
unser bett ist kaputt team grün war es
hätten wir komplett außer acht gelassen
okay wir verstanden uns jetzt einfach in
die mitte ja ich hab jetzt sowieso
nichts mehr also scheiße alter team grün
gibt es ja auch noch hat jetzt ihr team
hat nicht gefehlt
neben noch nicht bekannt aber ich bin
grad bei team grün in der base bist du
auch kommen ganz hilfreich überlebt es
eh nicht mehr
ich habe eigentlich auf ein halbes knapp
ein halbes jahr ein halbes jahr tot
scheiße wie kannst du das auch machen
ich würde nicht rechnen die monsterwelle
zerstört habt ihr geld weiter jakub mir
wenigstens noch zu machen 16 gold alter
was soll ich denn jetzt machen ich kann
ja nicht überlaufen du kannst du uns
gehen da ist niemand mehr nicht mal
blöcke habe ich du kannst du uns gehen
echten lange du sagst 16 gold gekauft
hier auch mal ein ändert perle einfach
da kommt an da kommt einer kommt ein
nice heizöl man ja ich dann zu uns
herunter geboxt alltag auf den appell
und wer viel zu team zu team gelb weiß
einfach team gelb ist okay ich leute zu
uns dann hol dir die eine perverse
zutiefst sagt man wenn einer kommt man
hier auch mal abgeschossen alter den
grünen zum gelb
wer sonst auch diesmal wieder die uhren
sind gekauft die einfach die nfl und
damit gab junge mann jetzt sind da
hinten noch alle in der mitte
dass ich mal länger leben als du kaufst
mache ich bin dabei wird aber wenn du
die töten kannst jetzt einfach was
fressen alter wenn wir ein bisschen geld
übrig hat koch die noch gold ab erhalt
nenne das die zwei extra herzen hasst du
verlierst werden gezwungen da stimmt
einfach weil ich die ender perle
bestimmt falsch werfe oder so du
schaffst das
es wird richtig
die verfolger geworfen
nein was vertraglich an slow selten
ender perlen würfe geübter ender perlen
würfe geübt auch gut
du hast noch viele chancen eigentlich
egal ich mache das jetzt du bist allein
gegen haye krankhafter von links tod zu
dienen
ich brauche ein ding aber man sieht dass
du tot bist dann ist ein name so denkt
ach so ok ich forschte eigentlich ein
energydrink man wenn du sie sehen kannst
du dir auch ein energy drink und macht
tab ist muss man schreiben omg winter
ein bisschen hinter dem team grün
gewesen kommt einfach die oft hin gelb
oder soll ich mal machen ja machst
einfach weil team gehabt von denen leben
das ist aber team gelb hat ihr recht
schlau eingebaut
also mit kisten geht dann baust dich am
besten oben drauf und dann gehst du
runter so wow cassone sind auch schon
wieder 17 eineinhalb minuten alter ok ok
go loca loca schön heiß auf dem mit der
rüstung der andere kann eh nix junge tut
doch schafft jetzt
der hatte einfach auch ein eisen schwert
effekt eine spannende runde total
abgelöst eigentlich alles waren
intensive runde alter auf jeden fall gut
wenn ihr die anderen sehen wollt könnt
ihr heute noch bei dir ja
die kommt dann eventuell ist sie schon
mal max gekommen junge bitte einfach nur
team gelb sterben na ja gut wir sehen
uns dann in der anderen runde bei max
wieder rein was gut